[Music]
let's go to malachi next in rogers
arkansas malachi how can we help
hi uh yeah thanks for taking my call
george and ken i really appreciate
it um so i i really struggled with how
to phrase this question um but i'm 22.
i've got a beautiful wife and two
adorable children um i'm only making 16
an hour i don't have a degree thankfully
i don't have any debt um but our rent's
going up it's it's getting to the point
to where
um we can't really do anything
significant i can't put away for
retirement um i can't put anything into
a savings account
and basically the most we could put into
savings each month each month is about a
hundred dollars
um you know just leaving even just
leaving a little bit of extra money for
you know unexpected stuff or
you know um like if we need to get an
extra thing of diapers or something so
i'm really just not sure what to do um
as far as options go there's not really
anything else in my area that's
comparable
um what are you doing now you know a
family box right um as far as career
goes yeah
um i worked at a t-shirt shop um which
is i mean they're super nice people um
and it's a great gig and it you know i
was unemployed prior to that and so i
don't know unemployed but for a time i
had been
um
and so but i mean there's really not
much room for advancement if i stay
there 20 years i'll probably be doing
the same thing i'm doing today how big
of an area is rogers arkansas
i mean it's the it's in the northwest
arkansas area so it's pretty big i think
it's one of the fastest growing areas in
the country um but it doesn't um
really have any of the industry that i'm
wanting to go into what industry do you
want to go into publishing
publishing book design formatting and
like typography and stuff okay well so
if that's the industry you want to be in
where where are those jobs
i'm i'm i'm really not sure okay let me
help you out okay so nashville's got a
lot of publishing jobs okay you need to
do your homework on this you know
because you can't sit there you've got a
family to take care of and 16 an hour is
barely getting you by and it's also 2021
and you said you're in a really good
area northwest arkansas my goodness
walmart's out there bentonville all that
area and and we're in a situation where
uh companies are begging people to show
up
dude you can make way more than 16 an
hour
and you should be making way more than
16 an hour not at the t-shirt shop it's
time to get busy this is an income issue
you've got to discipline you've got the
know-how you're doing a good job you
still have enough income
and and so we have two issues we have
short term and long term the short term
that's what i just addressed i'm kind of
kicking in to see the pants and going
get out there if you've got to drive a
delivery truck you can make 20 22 an
hour okay get out there and get busy
you're not wanting to go into t-shirts
anyway so go wherever wherever you can
go right now and get more income now
then once you get stable and you can
breathe a little bit
then you can allow yourself to say okay
if i wanted to move to the nashville
area to get into publishing or new york
or wherever wherever you got to do your
homework that type of work you want to
do where are the best places to do it
it's not just an area where are the
companies at that are looking for talent
are you qualified if you're not malachi
what is it going to take for you to get
qualified how much is that going to cost
based on your budget how long is that
going to take well these are questions
you need to answer after you start
making more money and get some margin do
you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah absolutely come on yeah i
appreciate you kicking me in the butt a
little bit listen you got a lot to offer
you hear that more thank you yeah you
know what you need you need a picture of
that family you get a picture of that
future
in your head all the time get out there
man if you got to do two jobs right now
there's plenty of money to be made
you have an income issue that's it get
the income up walk the baby steps out
get called qualified for the future that
you want and step into it you got this